موقفه المانيا حيل تسليم اوكرانيا دبابات
ليوبارد لم يتغير لا جديده بعد بخصوص
مساله ذبابات اليوبارد لكنني اتوقع صدور
قرار قريبا كنت قد شجعت الدول الشريكه
التي تمتلك دبابات جاهزه للعمل بان تبدا
تدريب قوه الاوكرانيه عليها مساله السماح
بتزويد كيف بالدبابات القتاليه الالمانيه
الصنع تضع برلين تحت ضغوط من اوكرانيا ومن
اعضاء داخل حلف شمال الاطلسي الطريق
الوحيد ولا سلام دائما
اوكرانيا بانظمه ثقيله ومتطوره لتمكن من
مواجهه القوات الروسيه بولندا بدورها وصلت
حتى التحذير من انها مستعده لارسال
المدرعه الى اوكرانيا حتى وان لم تكن
المانيا قد وافقت بعده على ذلك ولا تقتصر
الضغوطات على الخارج فحسب فتردد المستشار
الالماني او لاف شورتز يقابله تصريحه
وزيره خارجيه بلاده التي اعرضت عن استعداد
بلادها للسماحل وارسو بارسال هذه المدرعات
بالمقابل عاد الكرملين للتحذير من ان
ارسلها لن ياتي باي خير على علاقتي بين
روسيا والمانيا وسيترك اثرا لا يمحى
وتملك جيوش اوروبيه عداد
وهذا ما يشكل ميزه كبيره لانه يمكن ان
يسهل الحصول على الذخيره وقطع الغيار
وتبسيط الصيانه لكن القانون الالماني
يلزمه كل بلد يملك اسلحه المانيه طلب
الاذن من برلين قبل ارسالها الى دول خارج
الاتحاد الاوروبي